- So wait, how did you end up
getting into acting though?
How did that happen?
- So strangely I got in through
sports, through basketball.
So that's been a passion of mine.
I grew up playing basketball.
Actually, I played in high school,
got a scholarship, played in college.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- And one day, a buddy of mine,
this kinda is gonna go
back to pre cell phones,
where people used to
yell out your window, yo!
Called me out the window, "Ramon!".
So I look out my window
and my boy is there,
Bobito Garcia, is a DJ as well.
And he's like, "There's this Nike event.
"Do you want to come?"
And I was like, mm,
again, a little reluctant.
He's like, they're giving
away free sneakers.
I was like, I'm there, done.
(audience laughing)
So I go to the event.
And I could do this one trick,
which was I could spin
a ball on my finger,
keep the ball spinning, put it on a pen,
put the spinning ball on the
pen in my mouth, no hands.
- How did you learn to do that?
- The Harlem Globetrotters.
So I would watch them as a kid.
- No, everybody watches
them, but we can't do it!
(audience laughing)
But I slept with my ball.
I named her, her name was Betsy.
I mean, it was a thing like.
- Oh, my gosh!
- You know?
What it did for me was
amazing, this round object.
For awhile I traveled around the world.
doing halftime shows and performances.
- So cool.
- Before acting.
Nike then was like, hey,
come be a part of these commercials.
That's what put me in front of the camera.
- And you liked it.
- I was like, I liked it.
Yeah, it's funny how like
the dance, the basketball,
somehow all kinda incorporates
into a a bit of performance.
- Yeah, 'cause it's all
a form of performance,
I guess, yeah.
- Exactly.
- Do you still know how to do the trick?
I'm challenging you.
- Maybe.
- Okay.
- Do we have anything
so I can?
- Oh, it's so
interesting, we do.
- Oh, just by chance.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
- Let's get the basketball!
(audience applauding)
And course, the Pilot G-2 pen,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
Pilot loves celebrating
unstoppable people like Ramon.
So, okay, let's see if you can teach me.
- Let's see, so here's this.
I'll start with this.
- Yes, no, you're up here.
You're gonna have to try too.
- Come on up, absolutely.
- You're not getting outta this.
Oh, my God!
- Oh, just?
- [Audience] Oh!
- [Kelly] What?
- All right, so here we go.
Kelly, I need you to hold
this incredibly strong.
(Kelly shrieking)
And don't move.
- Incredibly strong.
- Don't move, just solid.
Don't move.
- I'm very strong.
I'm very strong.
- [Ramon] There you go.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- Ah!
- You know what, I'm not
gonna leave you here alone.
- Uh-oh.
- You hold that.
- It's still happening.
(audience cheering)
(Emma shrieking)
Ramon, oh my gosh!
- Wow.
- Oh, now you're just
showing off, Ramon! (laughs)
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
That is incredible!